pues ella tiene culpables en el crimen
del asesinato de la hija de la ex under
divina andaría divina y tal y como se
esperaba los indicios que ha presentado
moscú apuntan directamente hacia quien
según el servicio federal de seguridad
fsb el heredero de la caja es soviético
se trata de una obra de los servicios de
seguridad ucranianos en suelo ruso una
agente de los servicios o craneanos de
nombre natalia book entró en rusia el
pasado mes de julio y fue ella la que
llevó a cabo el asesinato de daria
dubina ella hizo activar el exclusivo
por control remoto a una distancia
prudencial fue siguiendo el coche de
daria dubina desde otro vehículo marca
mini cooper después de haber cometido el
crimen salió por carretera hacía estonia
atravesando la región rusa de pskov